okay guys what up welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today
i have my morning coffee
and i also tell you what happened to me
today i found out i'm demonetized on
instagram
oh my gosh guys
i'm so bummed i made okay i didn't make
a lot of money but i made like three 400
bucks a month off of instagram
oh this hurts my soul okay well
fine fine fine fine okay
anyways
and today i'm going to talk about
something that can be lonely at times
and why i feel like i don't really
relate
with people my age like i've always just
felt mentally like older
and i don't know how to describe this
but i felt like this from like such a
young age like i've always felt like
mentally
i'm just older than people my age
um
like
i drank in college okay that was my
thing i had four years
drank some booze you know
did that
and
at the end of the four years i kind of
realized that
all these people that i was hanging out
with at parties like weren't my real
friends like maybe
there's like one or two that i made
doing that stuff but
even those like
those girls i could probably still talk
to today like i i wouldn't consider them
super close anymore
um
so when you're a 25 year old that
doesn't drink and i want to clarify what
i mean when i don't i say i don't drink
i might drink one to two times a year um
i kind of always try to see how long i
can go without it
so but
it's like twice a year
you know what i mean like
um
and i don't really go out i don't really
go to clubs
um i have and if i do like i don't drink
but
if i do it's maybe
like i don't remember the last time i've
gone to a club i prefer pubs or bars
that are a little more laid back but
it leaves you kind of lonely to be
honest because
most girls your age just want to like
get [ __ ] up and like drink and party
and like do all that stuff and
i don't mind you know like having fun
and like doing that stuff every now and
then but i've just always been like a
hard worker and there's
goals that i feel like i want to
accomplish now as quick as i can because
i know like the rest of my life i'm not
really going to be able to do that stuff
like um
you know a youtube show like when else
am i going to do that so i'm going to
work hard like living and playing
volleyball in london
when else in my life am i gonna be able
to do that
um i wanna do a performance like i wanna
do a show
um i play guitar
and that's just sort of the stuff that
like takes up my free time
and like sometimes it's kind of lonely
because a lot of like the friends you
make are
aren't really like near you so you find
yourself kind of
alone a lot even though i have people in
my apartment like three times a week
um and it's a little foreign to me
because i just grew up with
siblings
and i was talking to my dad about this
and he he tells me this is why people go
back to their hometowns
because those are the people that kind
of know you they know how your family is
they know who you are and i think some
people try to run away from that but
and i did too for a long time i really
didn't
i didn't love my hometown but like the
older i get the more like that's where i
see myself going back to
if i can obviously like i'll be
married hopefully
and a husband but
i don't know that's my morning thought
today it's like sometimes
not partaking in like the fast life
leaves you kind of lonely but
what i've noticed is that like usually
in five years i'm happier because i've
worked harder at being thinner or i've
worked harder at
making money or doing something that i
love or like whatever
i was chasing instead of the partying
like i end up happier but
like the process can be lonely at times
so
i don't know let me there's a lot of
people that watch this channel
that maybe have advice on this so let me
know what you guys think in the comments
don't forget to subscribe bring that
notification bell and i'll talk to you
next time